but dude it was like you guys are so
stupid oh my [ __ ] and you know what
those comments don't hurt my feelings i
was just trying to sit there and wrap my
head around it just like what
why are you so mad
[Laughter]
why are you so like
[Music]
and i just was cracking up for the past
couple days and it's just like i'm i'm
dying laughing and some of the stuff i
started writing to people just to make
them even more mad yeah and i'm dying
laughing on the other side okay well now
i'm being an [ __ ] so i just in five
four three two one hello everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain
podcast making sure these goddamn
microphones okay
i've been having issues lately man bro i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on man
i've we i had two other podcasts with my
buddies pat and nick and then nick's
[ __ ] mike was off
and i had to lose two podcasts
that almost happened for the podcast
with me and that too yeah i know so what
so i found out what happened with yours
is that so i have so if you guys want to
start podcasting right and you're using
something like like a zoom recorder
right which is a
it's like a 300 digital
field recorder right well
you need something to boost the signal
so you get something called a cloud
lifter so i didn't have your mic plugged
into the cloud lifter which is why the
levels were so
okay so i i i was like racking my brains
over it i'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on like throughout the whole park you
kept looking at it and fiddling with it
i'm like i'm like why the [ __ ] i was
like yo you're a soft ass [ __ ] voice
man i was getting a hell of that
it's like one of those feelings it's
like when you
when you're
this is what it felt like it's like if
you guys can relate you guys ever just
leave your keys somewhere
and you felt like you did have it then
you place it somewhere while you're in a
hurry to leave and when you go back your
keys are missing yeah but you have to go
but you have to be somewhere at a
certain time yeah that's what it [ __ ]
felt like and i was pissed i was getting
[Laughter]
people were listening to the podcast and
they went back to the video because they
wanted to see oh make sense
because if they're just listening to it
on the audio form they're like what the
[ __ ] is going on i don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening man
hey to be fair i didn't know what's
going on either i didn't get it either
dude everything here is really [ __ ]
janky man if you go to other people's
podcasts like i've i've been on set like
people don't know how small this room is
this is actually a very this is the
smallest room in the house yeah and i
just make it work other people they have
a producer there right uh the they have
a show runner yeah they have somebody
running a live switch or all this other
[ __ ] yeah this is literally just myself
says diy right yeah diy project i edit
all the podcasts myself i do everything
by myself so when people think that this
is a whole production it's not i just
kind of learn on the go and on the fly
so but an important lesson to the young
folks out there is that if they say they
want to do something like this and they
say oh i can't because i don't have the
resources i don't have a team whatever
nah man
living proof right here he's doing it
all sleep for no reason it's because i'm
too cheap to hire people dude i'm just
like oh this is expensive
but it's but it's true though like in
today's society if you want to learn how
to do something the information's out
there i'm not saying that it's easy it's
actually very [ __ ] hard yeah
especially when it came to editing this
audio there was i didn't know how to
[ __ ] do it and i only recently
figured out a good flow to make sure
that it works and i downloaded the right
programs to make sure i clean up the
audio right so when you start doing
podcasting one of the biggest things
that you guys have to deal with is audio
bleed like audio bleed is the hardest
thing because you have three mics and
even if you hear somebody talk that's
distant it's not that loud it's just two
people is fine but three mics pick it up
it sounds crazy that's why when you hear
us every when everybody laughs it kind
of sounds echoey yeah the only way to
get rid of that is if you go through
each individual track and you just cut
out everybody else's mic i'm not doing
that
at all so you're just gonna hear the
[ __ ] echo that's all that it is
there's a balance there's a good balance
right like what you can realistically do
and have time for and you know i'm not
sitting here like
going scrubbing through this whole thing
for a [ __ ] year right right if i pay
somebody they better do it well because
not only that is that you have to watch
everything back in real time over and
over again and make sure all these
little spots are it's not and it's like
not a five minute segment dude it's like
hour hour and a half right no and thank
god i don't give a [ __ ] about what i say
like because if i did i would have to
delete so much [ __ ] but you know a lot
of people that came on here there's
certain stuff i had to take out because
of how i don't want to call them soft
but they are very sensitive about it
yeah they're sensitive about the things
that they say about how because they're
worried about jobs future casting stuff
it's like [ __ ] man
i don't
it's so hard to live like that well in
the instance with our friend well we
won't drop the name but remember when it
was the whole blm stuff we were talking
about that yeah that pertained to like
his career so that's why you know you
have to take that down right yeah yeah
yeah but
other things when it's just like you're
worried about what you said it's like
come on man like dude i'm talking about
there's people who have been on you who
have a reputation for speaking their
[ __ ] mind and you start to realize
that oh you don't speak your mind you
you actually you actually just say
things that sound um
very loud but it's already stuff that
people agree with yeah so you're
confident in getting loud with this [ __ ]
so you're still pc you're still staying
within that lane you're following a
crowd and then you're just following
what other people say like for example
like so recently i did a review on uh
shanghai right yeah
well look under understandable if you
really like the film and somebody
[ __ ] on the film that you didn't
like
you could feel a certain way about it
but the moment the video what 40
dislikes it's like damn you
[ __ ] just
wave man you caught that wave but here's
the thing yeah i could give a [ __ ] less
right you know why because it's just a
[ __ ] movie yeah well that and it's
just an opinion exactly it doesn't have
to be agreed like people can disagree
they can hate on it it's like that's
just what one man or two men whatever
think
that's it it's not like you're saying
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] and you know
whatever exactly it was just a critique
or a thought of a film from a marvel fan
of what they thought about the film
which i thought that's how it was going
to be perceived yeah and then my friends
were texting me like dude people are are
so mad and they're cracking the [ __ ] up
because they're not entertainment yeah
they're just laughing at these people
who are so mad over this film and they
can't wrap their head around it yeah and
i could cut i understand it but i still
think it's ridiculous right because
there's a lot of things that i like that
people dislike and it's okay right i
don't dislike i don't get mad i don't
get incest by it's like it's just oh you
don't like something that i like well
here's the thing i just don't understand
kind of like the commitment to writing
so hard for something or someone that
you don't know that they don't they
could care less about you you want to
hear the funniest [ __ ] comment like
this one had me cracking the [ __ ] up i
was dying laughing i was thinking about
doing like a comedy sketch of this
because somebody wrote it's like you're
just jealous because you wish you were
shang chi
could you imagine if i was shang chi bro
that would be the funniest [ __ ] film
dude especially that there's a part in
the movie where he has to take off his
shirt yeah
dude
i just take it off you guys just see
this
it's almost the most disappointing part
of the film you're gonna have to i'm
sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i didn't like the film
dude everybody's gonna tell me to put my
[ __ ] shirt back on dude rotten
tomatoes [ __ ] twelve percent yeah
i think twelve percent you'd be lucky to
get [ __ ] crack me the [ __ ] up because it
goes into this thing of like oh this
person doesn't like this film yeah this
person doesn't like me this person
doesn't like my thoughts this person
hates everything about asian americans
this person and it just goes into the
spiral people start battling these fake
ghosts that don't exist man it just
actually reminds me of a video that i
saw recently on youtube too is uh this
guy who reviews like music albums and
all that and he had a conversation with
the drake stan uh because this guy
didn't review a certified lover boy too
favorably and this stan is just like
he's so fr he's trying to keep his cool
but every time this guy starts to say
something somewhat in the territory of
negative he just starts going oh my god
man i swear to god you don't like drake
you hate dre why do you hate him so much
man like he's done so much great stuff
and i'm like dude i understand you like
his music man but it's okay if other
people don't like it you know but that's
the thing too art is open for
interpretation
completely that's what makes it art
that's why when people do reviews of a
film it's just how they view it or how
they see it
it doesn't invalidate your feelings
about how you felt about the film
absolutely it's just you should listen
to it as oh i can see why this person
didn't understand this part or why they
felt a certain way right which we were
very very thorough about those reasons
and even in the comments i was i had
some great conversations with people in
the comments because i really wanted to
see yeah and this person i was going
back and forth and i could see his
perspective and he could see mine and it
was a dope conversation which i thought
was going to happen right but dude it
was like you guys are so stupid i'm like
[ __ ] and you know what those comments
don't hurt my feelings i was just trying
to sit there and wrap my head around
it's like what
why are you so mad
[Laughter]
like why you so mad you're so mad bro
you mad yeah
and i just was cracking up for the past
couple days and it's just like i'm i'm
dying laughing and some of the stuff i
started writing to people just to make
them even more mad yeah and i'm dying
laughing on the other side okay well now
i'm being an [ __ ] so i just i stopped
doing that but it was it was it was
interesting seeing that right because
let's go i mean we're going to talk
about this either way right because i
wanted to talk about this um
three hot albums dropped right and we
don't really do since we're going to go
into a review mode any anyways
uh drake dropped an album certified
loverboy kanye west dropped donda
and then uh nas dropped um
king's disciples king's [ __ ] hell
dude wait was king's disciple right
that's what i believe i don't know i
just have it on repeat and haven't even
looked at the album hold on hold on hold
on i'm pretty sure it was
called uh let's see
oh sorry king's disease king's disease
sorry sorry yeah king's disease you know
what's interesting too i'm starting to
wonder too right just because of the
drop of the album i wonder if their beef
was orchestrated or if it was [ __ ]
real with uh yay and drake yay and drake
no i think there's some real like
animosity there because it stems back to
um like i think three or four years back
or five years it's a while ago yeah
right when
basically like drake was uh writing for
yay that's kind of where it all stemmed
from and then there was kind of like a
little hubla around that and then the
whole pusher coming out with the diss
track oh drake was writing for yay yeah
drake drake was helping yay work on his
album and drake i mean uh yay invited
drake out to wyoming him and 40. oh and
what no no was it wyoming or
montana
somewhere somewhere uh no disrespect to
those states but [ __ ] somewhere yeah
yeah somewhere in the middle of america
uh but
yeah drake went out there but then
apparently like before he got out there
40 was just gave drake a heads up saying
like yo
the vibe here seems kind of weird like i
i really don't know what it is but i
just thought you should you know kind of
know that before you get here and
drake's whole thing was that he didn't
really think much of it but then
yeah later on you know [ __ ] kind of hit
the fan and then even with like pusha
coming out with this and drake
drake was under the impression that
yay was the one who gave him that
information about him having a son
because it wasn't widely known
and
what was that track the adonis or
something adonis yeah that was the name
of his son yeah which by the way one of
the coldest [ __ ] diss tracks i've
ever heard of my [ __ ] life yeah yeah
and then so that's kind of like what
started this whole thing and um
drake actually had a follow-up dis
record to that but did you hear did you
see the interview on uninterrupted with
lebron
no no i don't even see it so yeah
basically drake was saying he had a
follow-up to uh the adonis diss track
and then he decided not to release it
because he said on that diss track it
was
taking it to a place
that was
like he didn't want to go there you know
he didn't want to take it there because
at the end of the day it's like
this is just
beefing on wax right it's a part of
hip-hop but then because pusha made it
so personal
he was like okay the gloves are off now
and i'm gonna have to really take this
so i don't know what he was alluding to
i mean it sounded like to me he was
saying he had like a lot of dirt and
personal information on pusha and that
it could have gotten really ugly from
that standpoint but i don't know i don't
know he just he was kind of vague about
it on an uninterrupted but the fact is
is that that this record does exist he
didn't make a follow-up but he just
never released it drop it immediately
i want to hear it now yeah i want to
hear it so [ __ ] bad but yeah
i just i just i remember meek mill and
drake had beef too right and i was
surprised meek mill [ __ ] came back
with something shitty yeah i think i
think um that kind of like gas straight
up too because like when he got into
that battle with me meek is supposed to
be this like street battle rapper yeah
and a battle rapper and then like drake
just
he just killed him yeah what i mean i
mean it wasn't even much of a kill it
was just like the the opposition was so
[ __ ] weird yeah right and it took me
a minute to drop the dick i'm like yo
man it's passed yeah like you've rip
already man yeah
when he came back with his disc i'm like
oh i forgot about this yeah exactly too
late
and on top of that it was garbage so you
know but then they squashed it why did
pusha t and drake had beef though
i think it stemmed from um because it
drake's like burgeoning beef with kanye
also he was just backing up yeah yeah
yeah yeah push it you know because
pusher and and good
music and and yay yeah he [ __ ]
destroyed him though that [ __ ] hurt my
feelings dude yeah that was i'm not
going to
we talked about it when it dropped it
was a crazy dis record and then it was
like okay like
drake what's he gonna come back because
i i hadn't counted him out at that point
i was like okay
he could come back with something crazy
too but we just got to see but it just
kind of ended there and then it faded
away you know did you like drake's album
the new one that came out ah
honestly it was really forgettable for
me you piece of [ __ ]
you have any idea how many good things
drake has done for the community okay
let me let me he was in a wheelchair all
right
jimmy yeah [ __ ] degrassi oh [ __ ]
dare you you hate paraplegics all right
that's how these arguments go by the way
here's here's a
my opinion about drake is that there's
no denying his
ear for music and talent and like just
having good taste in general right when
it comes to like
pop culture influencing pop culture and
making music this podcast is brought to
you by wordtune my friends every year
u.s businesses waste over 400 billion
dollars on bad writing because that
causes confusion in business guess what
it just takes too long to get to the
damn point better faster writing means
better business which is why your team
needs word tune for
teams i use this any time i write a
business email because your boy is
notorious for not understanding how to
write emails businesses need
this you can use word tune anywhere
you're running online including google
docs slack outlook web and what app you
can try wartoon for free at wardtune.com
slash brain my listeners can get a
discount for their team today at
wardtune.com slash brain are you looking
to elevate your entire team's writing
wartoon improves writing efficiency up
to four times better faster writing
means better business start writing with
wartune at wordtune.com
brain um but for me i feel like after
nothing was the same
really nothing was the same for drake
like he who he was an artist up to that
point and then who he became after that
i feel like there was a pretty drastic
shift now some hardcore drake fans might
not agree with me on that but if you
kind of look at the trajectory i feel
like drake still had
a pretty
unique identity of himself up until that
point yeah but then after that what
followed i think it was the collab album
with future right so after that it was
just him hopping on waves of like
basically collabing with people who
started a certain wave or a style that
was getting popularized but maybe not on
a pop culture level but by drake kind of
co-signing and riding that wave on it
with him not only kept him relevant it
gave them shine and you know also gave
him shine right because it was like new
and like interesting and popping but
people have accused him of being a
culture vulture because of that yeah
it's like he's not original he's just
basically swagger jacking but doing it
in like a very
incognito way because he's also kind of
like giving them a platform to shine so
it's like kind of hard to hate on that
too yeah but at the same time you can't
say this dude is not swagger jacking
because he is he's
if you if you're looking at it in the
most like
objective way he is biting off
somebody's style yeah but then
while biting off somebody's style he's
not necessarily just stealing he's also
collaborating yeah collaborating and
lifting them up too you know what i mean
so his the thing about his stuff too is
like listen
i'm not saying
you ain't gonna hear me
mine a [ __ ] ton of drake songs right oh
he got i mean bangers he got slaps bro
he has [ __ ]
bangers dude
my thing is when his album dropped and i
listened to it i'm like this stuff is
good
but it felt like i heard it already
yeah yeah i mean i think that he's
falling into his same tropes every time
yeah because you could say what you want
about kanye west
no two albums of kanye west is the same
right right and he's always like pushed
boundaries and after he pushed the
boundaries somebody takes what he does
and then kind of innovated after and
he's always been like a you know a
trendsetter right right right so with
this album i think it's it's also a
banger i think he has a bunch of [ __ ]
tracks there that are dope as [ __ ] yeah
just like i feel like i've heard it
before yeah yeah no for sure um i think
here's my theory on that is that
he's at such a
high level right now within the rap game
and within the music industry in general
that he doesn't really need to try it's
just more like he's gonna love it yeah i
just basically i'm gonna do whatever the
[ __ ] i want and no matter what it's
gonna break records is gonna be number
one because look every single album he's
dropped has been number one you know i
mean and and like when donda dropped it
broke all these records like streaming
records and whatever and then certified
level boys dropped and drake broke those
records right so yeah in your face
yeah that kanye doing the petty move but
did you see that like he pulled out ads
in toronto of donda it's just digital
billboards that says donda that's like
[ __ ] funny dude yeah well they would
dude he even did some other petty [ __ ]
too where i heard he like doxed him and
[ __ ] and he put his house address yeah
it's the grandpa yeah and then he took
it down
and that's just hella funny to me yeah
in the group in the group text that
drake was in he was talking about like
you know how he's survived bullies and
how he's gonna like body you know drake
or whatever and then drake uh posted
just this like really
like mysterious clip but it was pretty
clear what it was addressing he just
posted a clip on um on a story of him
laughing after after he
posted his address and stuff like he
doesn't say anything drake's just
driving in his car and just laughing and
he's like
you know that's just hella funny dude
that's some like preschool level [ __ ]
comebacks dude it's like hey [ __ ] you
dude i don't like your [ __ ] cool this is
where you live
and i'm going to show everybody i'm like
yo this is all [ __ ] crazy yeah that
should make me die
i mean granted it's not really a big
mystery of where drake lives i heard it
was like on google maps yeah well he's
the only [ __ ] guy who's living in
like a [ __ ] 500 million dollar
mansion or whatever you know what i mean
there's even if you know where he lives
you're not gonna get anywhere close to
his front door didn't he also like
release an unreleased track in donde or
something he like leaked it
who drake or some [ __ ] oh drake did yeah
i think so i don't know i think about
that and then also in
in certified loverboy i think he dissed
like swiss beats he disliked [ __ ]
kanye everybody
yeah i mean there were definitely shots
that um drake had taken
yeah yeah uh but yeah the whole beef
quote unquote beef between them has been
just very childish
it's never really turned into anything
substantial where it's like also too
it's just like two of the softest people
in the rat game [ __ ] beeping with
each other put some [ __ ] gloves on
and slap it up all right if you guys are
at this point like don't [ __ ] foot
around and just [ __ ] just go straight
forward then you know this each other on
wax like hundred percent just make a
disc record and yeah i don't mean soft
isn't like i'm any harder than that i'm
talking about you know there's a lot of
rappers who are murderers and gang
affiliates right right this is a guy
that did you know kanye west who i
personally his first three four albums i
[ __ ] loved there's a guy that made
the prep you look popular right and you
have drake whose music makes me wanna
[ __ ] piss while sitting down
you know it's like emo rap guy versus
you know the preppy rapper so it's like
this this beef doesn't really it's not
really tantalizing for me no for sure
for sure i mean i think everybody just
kind of looks at it as just a form of
funny entertainment it's not anything
serious or like
threatening
there's there's no real threat there
it's just two people well you know what
i i think drake has definitely taken the
higher higher horse in in this whole
beef yeah where kanye has acted a little
bit more childish and i mean i heard
this full [ __ ] lit himself on fire on
a performance who did kanye west
bro i think it was like a vma
performance where he [ __ ] lit himself
on fire for what just just out of shock
value dog so like i guess he was walking
around remember wait i think he was uh
he he made his album in what stadium
cleveland
oh i don't know i don't know what
stadium i'ma just google kanye west
lights himself oh you mean the listening
party yes the listening party he lit
himself on fire or some [ __ ] he lit
himself on fire at the listening part at
the donda listening party bro
i don't know about that
oh [ __ ]
you sure that's real this is real this
happened this happened at the listening
party he lit himself on fire bro
for how many seconds
so i guess what he was i forgot you guys
could probably let me know but he was
he was uh staying in that little jail
cell of a [ __ ] room yeah yeah yeah so
kanye west
sleeping in stadium or something
yeah and then they had no audio so you
couldn't hear like what they were
talking about he was at the atlanta
stadium okay and he was holed up in
there yeah yeah and i was reading an
article that he was walking around yeah
in the the flame retardant clothing and
so people are all thinking like yo this
is gonna be the next hot drop in his
line and [ __ ] yeah but it's not it was
just a clothing that he was gonna light
himself on fire with
yo
this fall is [ __ ] crazy bro so so
that's another thing to like really
point out too in the evolution of kanye
as a personality as an artist as a
musician
it's like
where has his mental health been during
that process you know because we know
everybody knows there's no denying that
kanye is a genius on some level right
and he's made some
incredible [ __ ] projects and there's
no question about his influence in pop
culture you know what i mean from the
clothing to the shoes whatever yeah
right
but
at what point did his mental health
really start deteriorating to the point
that it also affected his art you know
what i mean i mean for some people that
type of manic energy crazy manic energy
can can make the art better or or like
inspire it but in his case i feel like
there's been some really polarizing
projects where it was like oh man i
either hate that or love it which is a
good response anyway because people are
still talking about it whether they hate
it or love it
but to be honest man for me
i haven't
thoroughly enjoyed a kanye album since
my beautiful dark twisted fantasy that
was the last kanye album that i
thoroughly enjoyed yeah i'd even enjoyed
that one dude oh you didn't no okay
like
i don't know man there was a lot of
talks about him having like so many
ghost writers which is the reason why we
liked a lot of his [ __ ] right so when he
came out with college dropout uh we'll
say late graduation graduation
yeah graduation administration late
registration graduation yeah i ca i
think it's crazy how many lyrics i can
recite from those albums because i
remember listening to it and thinking it
was like next level [ __ ] right
especially when it came to his his
cadence and his uh
lyricism it was just so [ __ ]
different like even this line two he was
like mayonnaise colored benz i pushed
miracle whips i'm like dude that is a
[ __ ]
hot yeah ass [ __ ] line yeah and then
you know people were saying that uh
consequence was one of his ghost writers
and also the people and then when i
heard consequences album yeah it sounded
just like kanye west's flow right i'm
like oh maybe he did have a [ __ ] ton of
ghost riders yeah but you know
i think the magic the thing that i liked
about kanye just to go back to was the
fact that he always created music that
was challenging right and it took me a
few listens to get to like it because i
would first listen to him i was like i
missed the old kanye
and then i'm like oh actually i like the
new
do something different i'm like then i
missed the previous kanye yeah and i
listen to it again i'm like actually
this kanye's pretty [ __ ] good too
yeah and i think the great thing is is
that what he does with his albums that a
lot of other people don't do is that his
albums are a representation of where he
is personally at in life all the time
right right and and that can be a good
thing or a bad thing right um
i think wait wait awaits in heartbreak
right 808 well you want to talk about
emo rap and like sing and rap that's
really what inspired everybody yeah
everybody right but also
he wasn't the originator of that if
anybody was like
true og of that type of style t-pain
cudi oh cudi cudi was a very emo rapper
sing-songy type of rapper you know and
that's why kanye like linked with him
too it was interesting when he what was
the song that he came out that popped
off which one uh it was his first one
that popped off hughes every day and
night day and night yeah day and night
i
until this day i still don't like that
song
i just don't like lyrically i don't like
it yeah i don't like the off-key singing
i don't like any of that [ __ ] yeah and i
went back to listen to it recently and i
still didn't like it people don't
understand why i don't [ __ ] with cuddy
like they're like well if you like kanye
you should like cuddy i don't know
something about his like his like the
way he flows i i just can't [ __ ] with it
i'm not saying he's not a dope artist
just for me it's just not my taste yeah
no i get it i get it that it's not it's
not everybody's cup of tea with it with
this style of music i think it's also a
very polarizing style of music too um
but yeah i mean 808 and heartbreaks was
kind of like a deviation from what was
popular within the hip-hop scene and
community at the time so yay has always
kind of done his own thing for better or
worse right
doing his own thing sometimes led for me
personally to like something i really
[ __ ] with and then other times it's
just like oh yeah i don't i don't really
know if i'm feeling that but i stopped
thinking about it in the terms of oh i
want the old kanye or you know this
kanye i just because then that's kind of
not allowing an artist to evolve and
grow right every artist has the right to
evolve and grow the way they want to and
the direction they go might not be for
you but that's okay because that's for
the artist to decide but then with this
donda album
the first of all was two hours long i
was like what the [ __ ] yeah that's like
a movie bro ridiculous it's already
ridiculous and it's not two hours
necessarily of music there's just a lot
of fillers in between those are one of
the most annoying things for me bro it's
like when there's a fire track in
between an eight-minute song yeah or
eight-minute track but then like it's
only dope right in between yeah like two
minutes of it is a is like music and
then it's like maybe skits or talking or
you know i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] but
anyway
when i listened to it
there were maybe about three or four
songs where i was like oh yeah that's
pretty dope believe what i say obviously
i mean i [ __ ] love that track but
that was more so cause like lauryn hill
and it took me back you know what i mean
and just like hearing lauren hill again
was
man such a breath of fresh air yeah yeah
for sure and then it made you wonder
what that collab might have been like if
they actually collab together at a time
and then so you look at just kind of
like the evolution of yay and what you
were saying how he used to be like
somebody who dropped really dope lines
but back then he was a backpack rapper
that's what he considered himself
because he was keeping himself in
company with like your most steps your
talib qualities right your commons right
and those are all people who were
considered conscious rappers i always
hated that term but yeah conscious
rappers and then he started to kind of
evolve into i think after his mother
passed away that's it's you can see it's
clear that was like clearly the snap
yeah yeah well snap or change or
whatever whatever you want to categorize
it as but there definitely was a change
starting from that point and then his
breaking up with uh amber rose i think
is what really inspired 808 and
heartbreaks you know i forgot that he
was with amber rose yeah dude yeah the
what was she she was like the she was
like um
she was in the forefront of [ __ ] shaming
yeah yeah yeah that was like that's like
her thing yeah don't [ __ ] shame me
for being a [ __ ] right right right that
was the thing yeah
what the [ __ ] happened to amber rose
well she has a kid with wiz khalifa god
damn
yeah for sure because i think that's who
she hopped to after yay and then they
were together
they were together for a while but i
don't think yeah they're together
anymore but anyway yeah so like when i
heard the donda album and just kind of
like
considering kanye's evolution as an
artist and i heard believe what i say it
made me think
i wish i got more of this kanye that i'm
hearing on this track whatever version
of kanye this is when i heard that i was
like this resonates with me on a level
where
i would want to consume the [ __ ] that
you're putting out but then it just kind
of became this like
really
i don't even it's like kind of messy to
me the whole album
and there was no like cohesiveness but
that's what we were saying every album
that he puts out yeah is a
representation of where he is in life
like just mentally frazzled
he's so [ __ ] erratic yeah and that
album is literally how he is right now
in his life yeah he's so [ __ ]
scatterbrained yeah like there was a
point where when i was looking at kanye
right and you know when his albums were
coming out i wasn't feeling it as much
but at the same time it seemed that he
had somewhat of a laser focus right
especially the way here's the thing too
like
kanye west became super polarizing
recently too because of his sentiments
and how he aligned himself with donald
trump
right and for a lot of people
specifically in the black american
community
he became the uncle tom he's like you're
a [ __ ] uncle tom yeah like you turn
your back to our community and but then
there was the other side saying like
look he's doing what he has to do
because kim kardashian got to meet trump
and then she started doing her work
through trump so there was you know two
things that were happening here at this
point yeah but this there was a point
where i felt like kanye was so precise
specifically with his clothing
you guys could say whatever you want
this man changed the face of fashion
this [ __ ] rapper right who number one
he actually did it even before the his
whole line his his whole you know clean
aesthetic line
he did it with the the popped up collars
like i remember in high school seeing
everybody with the pop collar doing the
double the double pillows oh yeah the
double polos the [ __ ] double polos
dude he was already changing the face of
fashion right when he started because he
was so different and everything that he
touched was [ __ ] gold look at this
right now you have any idea how hard it
is to make a [ __ ] fashion icon
sneaker yeah making shoes is so [ __ ]
hard how many brands have you seen that
are shoes that have been trying to enter
this space saying i am the next one yeah
and it has not happened this guy started
with nike
he had his brand with nike and in fact i
i actually designed these air maxes
which i [ __ ] wrecked i made two of
them and i wore them so much because
they went with everything
it was the solar red interiors the wolf
gray outside and then the neon green gum
bottom well that was a specific kanye
west color that nike had after he moved
to adidas you can't [ __ ] be anything
you can't custom make those shoes
anymore yeah pisses me off it makes me
want him to go back to [ __ ] nike so i
can remake those air maxes man
what the [ __ ]
well in his in his mind nike did him
dirty so that's why they kind of had
that red yeezys he had the black ones as
well the wolf gray ones yeah all that
stuff and then he goes over to adidas
adidas and then he does his yeezys yeah
the first one the turtledove ones yeah i
had those yeah bought it for [ __ ]
four hundred dollars that [ __ ] is worth
like three or four grand right now
i sold it for like 500 bucks idiot
you couldn't have known though that it
was gonna that was the start of like
something like that i mean i was going
through this phase where i was just like
i don't need material possessions and i
sold
all these shoes that i bought just
prematurely prematurely and i only kept
the ones that were given to me as gifts
and the stuff that i wear every day when
i gave up that one shoe i was like i'm
gonna wear this shoe yeah but then it
was worth like whatever 600 700 bucks so
i just sold it yeah and i'm like [ __ ]
man because i would i would i would be
wearing that shoe till this day and it's
just too expensive for me to ever buy
i'm not spending three or four sure for
sure for sure i mean at this point in
our life there's better things to spend
money on 100 dude i have i have a
[ __ ] uh travis scott shoe right here
yeah right now
sell it i was so you want to hear some
crazy [ __ ] i bought this i bought uh the
yeezys
uh
tail lights yeah right i love those i
don't have them you know why because
this [ __ ] company sent me the wrong
shoes they sent me three shoes oh that's
right that's right and then they sent
you the travis scott they sent me the
travis scots and i was like hey yeah me
being the good man that i am
this is what i said i emailed them i was
like hey you guys sent me the wrong
shoes yeah um i ordered this you guys
sent me something else
and they're like okay cool well we need
to receive the shoe before i was like no
no no send me my shoe and then i'll send
you these back yeah because clearly you
guys are [ __ ] up yeah i don't trust
you yeah send me my shoe and i'll send
it back and they're like well then you
can just keep it i'm like
do you understand that this shoe is
worth like four times the amount of the
shoe that i bought right like this shoe
right now is worth like three grand yeah
and the shoe that i bought was 300 bucks
and they did send you the yeezys too
they didn't they did it so you just got
these okay
i'll just keep this one yeah yeah dude
let it just [ __ ] build up in value
then man yeah man and you know what
here's the thing i'll show you it right
now
oh you got it right here right here
so they sent me these sb's right i was
like i don't [ __ ] wear sb's what the
[ __ ] do i look like guess which one it
was guys and it is the the paisley ones
yeah the catholic cactus jacks i think
these ones are called yeah the dunks
i would never wear this
i can't rock these yeah it's just not
something you can but you know you can
yeah you can pull it off if you wanted
to yeah but it's just not your cup of
tea it's not my cup of tea man
i am no hood man
i just can't i can't rock these like
this is not something that i feel like i
would ever look good in right because
i'm more you know simple more low-key
or if i do that i'm like more bright
colors or some [ __ ] like it depends but
this this right here you got to be
somebody special right to wear this and
i've gotten a lot of offers people want
these shoes if you guys want these i'll
give to you for ten thousand dollars
10 000 in bitcoin
the funny thing is like shoes every now
and then i have an itch to buy shoes
like last night i bought three pairs of
shoes oh my god right but it wasn't it's
nothing crazy though yeah okay okay just
like everyday wear yeah so i have
a couple issues that i really really
really like are these uh flyknit racers
they don't make them anymore but there
was so much that are made a bunch of
people have them and i bought a couple
that were used but they were used very
lightly but they were only a hundred
bucks okay so i bought them yeah well
i love these shoes so i wanted to buy
two more because i know i know one right
now i just had to repaint it
because i wore it out so much that's how
much i like these shoes you painted your
shoes yeah and it looks brand new i'll
show you outside it looks brand [ __ ]
new
but i had to paint it because i saw a
bunch of youtube tutorials which by the
way it's [ __ ] amazing what you can do
and apparently they use like acrylic
paints and it makes the shoe look brand
[ __ ] new that's how people customize
their shoes so i was like cool i'ma buy
these too and i was like okay your boy's
gonna start jogging so i bought another
shoe but the thing is i don't buy shoes
that are expensive anymore i only buy
shoes that i will definitely wear yeah
yeah and have you dude have you seen the
the the fakes game nowadays no i haven't
like they're called uas which is like
unidentified oh like authentic or
something yeah yeah yeah it's supposed
to be like a b grade yeah yeah or like
you know a reject of of the factory
production this is the crazy thing about
those yeah so you guys know i used to be
a really big sneaker head any jordan
from one to [ __ ] 12 i had it
i had stacks on stacks on stacks of
shoes
got rid of it because i said i went on
this like little you know i can be
better than the material things i have
sold all these shoes yeah well at the
time for every
authentic that i had i also had a fake
version of it yeah so i could walk
around in it
because i never wanted to put my feet in
the in the actual ones exactly yeah so
the crazy things like these fakes were
worth like 50 or 60 bucks and those
sites are taken down now well nowadays
these fake shoes are so [ __ ] good the
only way you can tell that it's not real
is like you have to get somebody who is
a professional who already has a shoe
look next to it side by side and then
make the comparison right that's how
authentic they are but they still cost
like 140 bucks yeah that's great because
i seen um kind of like threads on it
where people when for example when like
at this factory that was knocking off
the yeezys were making
trying to make it as
close to the real one as possible they
were going through versions and then
they would post like
the the updates on version two this is
what we change in version i'm like are
you
there's a thread about community
like community feedback hey you guys you
should know it should be like this it
should be so they're telling the factory
what they [ __ ] up on to improve on for
the next one and the factory would keep
improving on it there's like b grade a
grade yeah one above that [ __ ]
ridiculous and by the way too one of the
craziest things that i ever saw so
there's these ones the uh jordan one uh
band reds right the breads
black and red the crazy thing is one of
the biggest tells is smell
the second thing for i'm talking about
the old one smell and also the type of
leather in the material they're using
the exact same [ __ ] material yeah
those bread
the the bread band ones yeah they're
made with tumble leather uh-huh it's
made with tumbled leather i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on like this [ __ ] why
even buy the real [ __ ] yeah yeah i mean
that's probably one of the most knocked
off shoes anyway yeah yeah because it's
such an iconic shoe the other the other
issue with the fake ones are the toe box
the toe box wasn't right so it was
typically
really [ __ ] wide yeah and so you
could tell so it would be a jordan one
but the toe box looks like a [ __ ]
it's like a square
dunk so it was fake as [ __ ] the funniest
[ __ ] story ever too so
this local leaf
had to go in for an audition for like a
sneaker head type of thing yeah he had
to be a sneaker head or somebody who
likes shoes so everybody in the
auditions are wearing jordans nikes
whatever all the hottest [ __ ] so a while
back i gave khalif a bunch of my
replicas right like i gave him a heads
up i'm like bro these are faces they're
fake yeah they're fake as [ __ ] right so
like cause i would use them in sketches
yeah so when i'm in sketches i'm doing
all this other stuff and i need to move
around and run in there right right i
don't give a [ __ ] these are replicas it
doesn't matter yeah so he shows up and
is i gave him one of these i think it
was these fours these bred forbes right
and i think the jordan was doing a layup
instead of a dunk like they were like
they were like [ __ ] jordans yeah
like jordan it was it was [ __ ] french
it was a french-ass jordan shoot and so
he goes in the audition and then this
fool gets roasted by other other people
auditioning in the room sneakerheads
actual sneakers like yo are those
[ __ ] faces what do you mean it's like
jordan doing a layup
talk it's not even holding a basketball
to football
he's doing the eyes
he's doing a stiff arm yeah
bro i felt so bad he was like
i told you these are fake man yeah
that's the worst [ __ ] scenario to
walk in to with the big json dude just
to get [ __ ] roasted i was thinking
about just getting buying the reps and
just leaving here so people could wear
it inside the podcast because they're
not real anyways um yeah one shoe that
i've been actually looking at to try to
get is the [ __ ] uh old school pumps
remember those the reebok pumps i think
they're still around right yeah they did
a re-release of them but then there's
also there there was this company called
la gear i don't know if you heard ever
heard of him dude
what are you talking about you talking
about the light up [ __ ] yeah yeah so la
gear
made a pump version too so i used to
have a pair of those which were then
pretty much the knockoffs
yeah they got sued by reebok for that
actually oh did they
i had a bunch of those yeah i had like
two pairs of them because they were so
cheap so i was trying to find the la
gear version of it but it's like only i
think they only made it for kids i don't
think they they ever made it in adult
sizes but yeah that's one shoe that i've
been trying to find like uh the
knockouts version no well they're real
la gear's a real company but they were
just knocking off reeboks pumps you
would get those at payless
[Laughter]
i actually looked up la gear and on
their site they said they're coming back
really yeah it doesn't say when but they
said they're making a comeback so i'm
waiting man
that's [ __ ] crazy i'm waiting for
those pumps to come back dude if you
guys don't know man like growing up your
shoes were everything yeah it was like
people would
base your coolness yeah on your [ __ ]
shoe sure in high school i remember i
got these [ __ ] clean ass yeah white
ass air force ones dude everybody's like
yo that [ __ ] [ __ ] clean i walked
around thinking man [ __ ] yeah these are
clean i was just like walking around it
with my big ass baby blue teeth yeah you
know but like those things were like
those recognizable moments like people
valued your
your value as a human being based on the
[ __ ] shoes that you had bro in
elementary there was this white boy
named jordan and because his name was
jordan like you know he he thought he
was michael jordan like when he played
basketball he always had his tongue out
hanging like this and [ __ ] but his mom
i think he was she was a single mom like
spoiled the [ __ ] out of him so this dude
would have the freshest [ __ ] kicks
all the time every new shoe drop that
come out he would have him
i would be
i was so jealous man like
all the time the [ __ ] that i wanted just
one pair of he would have for like a
week you know what i mean and then it's
another new pair of shoes i don't even
know how and this is like when we're in
third grade man like i don't even know
if he had appreciation for what his mom
was doing for him but this podcast is
brought to you by raycon my friends
working looks different for everybody
especially these days you're working in
a chaotic environment endless conference
calls and what could make that so much
better than a pair of lovely
wireless earbuds such as raycons i
freaking love them premium audio if you
need a pair of wireless earbuds to take
you from conference calls to solo work
to zoom meetings raycon's work earbuds
are a game changer i freaking love them
and here's the biggest reason why
they've got six microphones it's a
system that cuts down on environmental
noises ensures my voice is crystal clear
on my calls super important how many
times have you used these stupid earbuds
where people don't know what the heck
we're saying they think it's all muffled
and weird well guess what there's also
active noise cancelling for maximum
focus and ambient mode for when you need
to hear the world around you and i love
the 32 hour battery life so i don't have
to worry about these things dying on me
the best they also have a 45 day free
return policy so right now go to buy
recon dot com slash brain work to get 15
off your recon or if that's by b u y r a
y c o n dot com slash brain work for 15
off raycons today by raycon.com
brainwork
bro he literally had every [ __ ] new
shoe that dropped and i'm like
these aren't cheap man
do you know that's that's why i have
half the sh you know the shoes that i
sold that were worth more like people
are like oh why are you selling those
yeah well it's because the ones that i
kept were the ones that meant to me
emotionally when i was a kid yeah yeah
like i got these aqua eights yeah but
they were a pretty general release when
they got re-released yeah there's a
shit-ton they're not worth that much
right they're probably still worth
retail maybe even right it's not about
that though it's about the emotions it's
about what you couldn't have when you're
growing exactly only poor people can
relate to that yeah you know that's why
people call me porn
pointed directly at me and that [ __ ]
hurt my feelings so bad what i'm saying
he's like holy [ __ ] poor people
no no no but i'm saying you know that's
why i relate to that too you know
growing up like money being always a
problem and everything it's like not
being able to have certain things that
you wanted
even if it's just one of like you're not
asking for a ton of it just like one of
it and then you get to the point in life
where you're a little bit older you're
making your own money you're like hey i
can realistically afford that now so now
i'm gonna buy it yeah you know that's
one of the reasons bro like i have this
[ __ ] like shelf filled with like just
all these different snacks because all
the [ __ ] that i couldn't get when i was
growing up like i want that i want a box
of rice krispies treats i want a box of
fruit roll up it's more so with that
granted i do love snacking but honestly
there's you know how much i eat bro like
there's no way i'm finishing any of that
it's just more so i remember i couldn't
get that that's why i started buying
like lunchables as an adult you know
what i mean like when i was like
disgusting things nah but i'm saying i
used to covet that [ __ ] so much who
didn't you know what i'm saying like
dude my mom would make me a better lunch
than that [ __ ] hundred times better
[ __ ] throw it on there yeah [ __ ] this
give me the lunch exactly but then you
got the kids and you see them pull out
the lunchables and you're like oh man
you know i wish i could have a lunch
that's trailer trash charcuterie dude
exactly that's what that [ __ ] is dude
but when we were younger we didn't know
better you know what i mean that was
just like the unattainable [ __ ] could
you imagine how much that hurt our
parents like our mom like makes this
by the way
yeah his bomb cuts hella good too it's
very rare that i go to somebody else's
home who says that their mom cooks
really well and it's really [ __ ] good
yeah like his mom could open up a
restaurant if she wanted it right could
you imagine your mom just taking like
hours to make all the different side
dishes to make the korean kimbap i know
right to you yeah you just go what the
[ __ ] is this
it's like you thought man [ __ ] this [ __ ]
mama again i told you give me some
lunchables and that's all i crave now i
crave my mom's food all the time sure
for sure but when we were young
that's what i'm saying it's just like it
was just unattainable whatever it was it
doesn't matter if it's lunchables pair
of shoes a shirt whatever the case is
it's just like we couldn't have it
because our parents didn't have the
money for it but i remember in
elementary school there was this kid his
name was ryan yeah
i liked american food so much because i
never got it and you know during the
time like when we were kids a lot of the
ingredients that were used in korean
food was really really cheap yeah like
like al also too this high protein diet
which is very expensive in american
terms or american american terms
american food
is costly because of the amount of
protein that you're eating yeah korean
food is the opposite yeah it's a lot of
rice a lot of vegetable side dishes
which don't cost much and then korean
food specifically is a lot of soups and
stews right that's the biggest
misconception about korean food because
korean barbecue popularized it so
everybody thinks korean food is korean
barbecue and all these meats but not
korea was a poor country historically
right and so growing up just like you
said or
like not us growing up but our parents
the generations before that that's what
they ate [ __ ] carb stuff carb heavy
stuff oh this is vegetables bodied by
rice
yeah stews
soups
that's authentic korean food that's
korean cuisine but like i feel like in
pop culture american culture people
mistaken korean barbecue as authentic
korean cuisine yeah korean barbecue is
it's really the popularity is very
korean-american yeah right yeah uh
k-town on it honestly was one of the
biggest places that really sparked it
off
specifically with the all-you-can-eat
thing yeah and now switching back to
non-all-you-can-eat because people want
quality over quantity but that okay when
i first came to la
that's all i hated
i ate korean all you can eat korean bbq
number one because i was poor and there
was one specific spot
yeah yeah yeah nine nine ninety nine
nine ninety nine yeah yeah are you
telling me yeah for
eat 9.99 if it's just brisket and and
pork belly that's good enough it's
amazing i don't even know how they
stayed in business yeah because i went
there like four times a week
i think they were scared of me like
every time i came in they're like oh
i would try to take these korean
barbecue joints out of [ __ ] business
and then could you imagine me being
there and then also when ed park was my
roommate his [ __ ] fat ass paul and
then paul paul would eat just as much as
exactly this was never as fat as this
yeah yeah we would demolish this stuff
yeah but that was the popularized
version of what korean food is so when i
what i heard from older heads now i
can't really verify its accuracy or the
history behind it but what i had heard
was that when they started immigrating
over to
l.a right
they started thinking about opening up
restaurants and was like wondering what
type of restaurant should they open and
because meat was such a rarity in korea
they thought oh we should do meat place
because that's like high-end for korean
food right so that's what it was
supposed to represent but then it just
became this other beast the status quo
is just like is that's what it is now
you know the meat consumption in the
united states is huge like if we have we
were talking to
um
[Music]
joe's girlfriend her name is hannah
she's from uh the uk
she looks at us like we're like what the
animals why do you guys have why is
everything so big here yeah like why
when why is it that when we bought when
you guys buy a box of cookies there's 70
cookies in this right right you feed it
honestly though our portions like it's
ridiculous compared to most of the world
it's crazy because she's saying that
about food in california i was like just
wait till i take you to texas or hawaii
let me show you what's up
dude when i was in hawaii i went to
zippy's yeah and you know i i remember
it being like oh just the normal portion
but i also forgot when i used to go to
hawaii i was like almost 300 pounds so i
ordered like
a loco moco from zippies and i ordered a
chili on the side and some soup which is
what i would normally get so i would get
this i would get the saimin yeah i would
get a side of chili and i would get a
loco moco oh [ __ ] that's making me so
hungry right now and i was able to eat
the whole thing yeah
yeah you ate all of that dude i ate that
whole thing [ __ ] one sitting easy dude
even just to sign in with all the carbs
yeah i get it dude
get it
only poor people
he was really [ __ ] fast
so when we went to hawaii recently i
ordered the same thing i finished a
third of it yeah i'm like holy [ __ ] this
portion is ridiculous this is some big
[ __ ] you realize that when she were
overeating yeah i just never knew and it
was delicious it was so [ __ ] good
yeah there's something about food and
nostalgia that always hits oh yeah no
matter how like i could eat at some of
the best restaurants in the world yeah
if you ask me what my meal is going to
be when i die i'm always going to think
about the food my mom made right and the
stuff that i grew up loving absolutely
absolutely because it reminds you of
something more organic something more
homey you know i mean yeah like you can
go to these michelin star restaurants
for the experience or whatever but like
is that what i would want to eat on a
like
not even on a daily basis but like every
weekend for example no i'd much rather
prefer like a hole in the before
french is fun
[Laughter]
got a little fancy there no like i much
rather prefer like hole in the walls or
just like these everyday places that we
go and eat at you know what i mean
because those are the places where you
have the memories like the feelings with
the people that you love and like that's
what you share you know and food is such
an intricate part of that breakfast
lunch and dinner what are they when you
die but the day before you die what is
it oh [ __ ] man it could be a set
breakfast would be traditional american
breakfast for sure like pancakes or or
waffles eggs
no no just that's the that's the one
right um
lunch probably is gonna be like so it
could be any american breakfast you
don't have anything specific nothing
specific yeah just american diner food
let's put it that way american diner
food because you know how much i love
them
okay um depending on the mood pancakes
or waffles um
bacon
sausage
over easy eggs hash brown very good you
can't even eat a third okay this will
[ __ ] eat this this will [ __ ]
this will [ __ ] eat like a runway
model dude
in this [ __ ] what are you
talking about all this food you're not
gonna know i like options bro just one
bite of each thing you know it's it'll
it'll feel the stomach and the heart man
and then uh for lunch i would definitely
go with a solid classic american burger
meal
um no frills just like meat cheese
buttered bun
maybe onions ketchup mustard and pickles
really simple you know with fries and a
soda dinner my mom's my mom's meal
whatever my mom would make probably
kaibi chim like because that's one of my
favorite dishes that she makes yeah with
like the panchan's like her kimchi
um
some
like namur that she does
like maybe some fried tofu with uh yum
yum which is the soy sauce yeah
ah that and i call it a day bro ready
ready to go you're such a simple [ __ ]
man dude american breakfast and an
american burger dude cause that's like
you know you don't even want like
sushi [ __ ] man you know what though i
take that back i take that back too late
you're ready no no no no no no no no no
no for lunch for lunch
time
no you died
[Applause]
you have to realize you literally just
made the choice and now you're dead i
know [ __ ] okay what i was gonna say okay
what i was gonna replace or or or
supplement the the lunch with the burger
just because i gotta have both of it is
i know it's a weird combination but la
meon any kind of lime in shin lamian oh
[ __ ] you know i gotta have that before i
die i [ __ ] like if you know if you're
asian korean like you know what that
means to you
everything yeah for sure so i can't die
without eating lamian one last time body
by lavender
his body
all carbs dude marielle did it doesn't
like lamian
no
every time i ate it she was like why do
you eat that stuff and i literally
backhanded her
nah you know what i don't believe that
because it wouldn't be in the backhand
it'd be the front head
okay
but she only but
to her credit she started liking it once
i started eating it all the time because
when i would eat it she was like you eat
it like it's the most delicious thing
you've ever eaten because it is
shin lamian black
with an egg a [ __ ] ton of green onions i
love a [ __ ] in there i love green onions
right yeah and i want my noodles not
cooked all the way slightly chewy
slightly authentic like a [ __ ]
italian al dente yes [ __ ]
beautiful
[ __ ]
like an italian yeah that's how i cook
it straight up al dente as [ __ ]
and then definitely i want two eggs
okay but but this is one of your death
meals then oh let me tell you my death
means
i love american breakfast
i eat it all the time specifically from
this spot called russell's in pasadena
one of my favorite spots money bro dude
they're waffles they're amazing yes
class and pie also has an amazing
[ __ ] waffle as well these are the
things that i want i didn't grow up with
so if i didn't have it before i died i'm
actually okay with it my breakfast is
oh so that's the breakfast meal okay
either that or it's noguti okay or it's
chappaguir you know what [ __ ] it it's
all chuck
by the way i'm gonna die anyway so i'm
just gonna eat this stuff and throw it
up and i'm gonna get ready for lunch
so it's going to be i'm going to have
shin nom nom black
right with a slice of american cheese in
it [ __ ] ton of green onions two poached
eggs inside eat that [ __ ] up skibbedy
wap good to go yeah also with some sang
kimchi on the side right okay very
[ __ ] good after that part of the
breakfast is done we're going to the
second course of breakfast you know
okay i have to be full that's not good
before okay all right all right we're
gonna have to go to norway okay right
yeah not no nobody
and we're going to do with the nobody
yeah is we're going to take a bunch of
seafood
dump it in that [ __ ] and then eat that
[ __ ] with a little bit of [ __ ] cold
rice in it um i don't know
i'm [ __ ] salivating right now
right i'm almost done with breakfast
i eat a lot
i'm gonna do
the [ __ ] chappa goody do uh-huh
actually choppage just checked by giddy
everything's straight we are going to do
chapagiri okay japa yeti is so [ __ ]
good dude yeah it's it's crazy how
sometimes i prefer getting over [ __ ]
the real what the [ __ ] is it called
that's how much i prefer
you love it so much it made me forget
the real thing exactly yeah that's my
breakfast done i'm probably easy 30
pounds heavier right now yeah so much
salt yes for lunch
i'm gonna have to go
either vietnamese or japanese and i'm
not sure what i'm gonna do here
so
this is a tough choice right because i
love japanese food yeah specifically
when it comes to the like the art of
sushi yeah yeah but sushi doesn't hit
this hard spot for me yeah it doesn't
it's good it doesn't hit me there yeah
so we're gonna go have to go to the
vietnam vietnam we're going to go to
vietnam this is what we're going to do
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we are going to take the best we are
going to take a bun me
with extra pate the number one special
that everybody [ __ ] gets head cheese
meatloaf [ __ ] cilantro pickled
carrots daikon double pate yeah cilantro
cilantro yeah [ __ ] delicious
[ __ ] the best [ __ ] ever man
eat that [ __ ] right that's gonna start
off the [ __ ] lunch and then we're
gonna go into a nice big comforting bowl
of [ __ ]
has to be a part of it and then on the
side i'm gonna have
she says it's all one meal you can't you
get so many options within a meal man no
this is this is how i eat this is how i
eat normally all right we're going to
have some bun sale but button sale has
to be there if you guys don't know what
ban sale is ban sale is a vietnamese
crepe it's yellow there is no eggs in it
that yellow is from turmeric um rice
flour and also coconut milk [ __ ]
delicious dude and you wrap that up
however the [ __ ] you want and some and
some herbs some all this other [ __ ]
delicious
now dinner time
is what my mom makes me okay this is
what my mom's gonna make okay she's
gonna do her
uh not pin pin
okay pintuck is one of my favorite
[ __ ] korean foods my mom makes it so
damn good yeah pinto is a mung bean uh
pancake that's fried yeah crispy as [ __ ]
thick
thick yeah delicious as hell beats pajan
any day i don't give a [ __ ] when anybody
says
all day and then on top of that my mom's
gonna make um
okay so pisi jigget is basically it's
like i think it's mung beans or it's
it's also um kong like whatever beans
are yeah
basically yeah and so they'll basically
grind it up with like water and then
you'll have like a kimchi jig or stew on
the bottom and then the pg on top
that's absorbs all the flavor of the
stew and you eat it with it it's [ __ ]
delicious we have some keratin on the
side with that amazing and then my mom's
cha-cha with that as well and a little
bit of kimbap and then you can stick me
in the stomach with a [ __ ] needle and
kill me tomorrow i'm oh okay
you know it's funny because japanese my
favorite cuisine but i didn't have a
japanese meal in there
well that's the thing too three of my
top favorite uh meals uh uh cuisines
japanese vietnamese korean top three
yeah everything else can suck my dick
yeah like those three are my favorite
actually i need mexican grown up in la
like mexican i love too yeah but mexican
is one of those things that i eat
probably the most okay there's four
great things
goddammit this is really hard yeah
this is really [ __ ] hard yeah listen
i love mexican food
oh [ __ ] huh yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying because you
put me like yeah you made me shock on an
answer
so i didn't get this thoroughly thing
but as you were talking i'm like oh [ __ ]
i left out so many things that i
probably would want to eat and taste one
last time before i die you know i love
mexican food though yeah
but
it doesn't hit that heart no then the
heartstring for me okay right like okay
i eat mexican food quite frequently i am
the [ __ ] korean taco king of lady
yeah yeah don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
else is i've eaten in almost every
[ __ ] taco spot here dude yeah i
actually blow up blew up like three or
four spots by myself
they literally follow me and they give
me free tacos because i blew them up
like i've never paid for a taco with
these spots yeah but avenue 26 is one of
them too right i know shout out to the
homie caesar man hey check out avenue 26
some of the best dollar tacos you can
ever have fire yeah fire dollar like
dollar something i think they're like
1.25 now but dollar taco spots they're
not all the same no it's not in the
inexpensive realm avenue 26 is my
personal favorite yeah there's ones that
are more expensive that that's good in a
different way yeah but avenue 26 is
really right all right shout out to the
homie caesar yeah i'm on a first name
basis [ __ ]
well guys no no no don't worry guys yet
though because we got to circle back we
got to circle back we didn't talk about
nazis king's disease at all right i
apologize we got we got we got
we got sidetracked with with yay's
craziness and then it led to food
somehow and i could talk about food for
[ __ ] days dude
but
[Laughter]
that right there my friend is the body
of a poor man
a poor
this is crazy this is an improvement of
what you said
no but like i mean we don't got to talk
about it in length but i just wanted to
touch up on it because it was like kind
of a contrast to like donda and
certified loverboy right like i didn't
even know i told you i didn't even know
what to drop you play me that played me
uh rare in the car with me you and ed
hottest [ __ ] track i was lying dude
dude
this is nice you know like
and you were saying oh you know he kind
of reinvented himself in that and and i
heard it like in his rhyme scheme like
in his cadence like oh [ __ ] this is this
is a rejuvenated nose that i've not
heard in a while this is what i loved
about that album yeah one of the hardest
things that you see when uh just for
anybody in general like as you get older
you get stuck in your ways and yeah
specific tastes yes and you just don't
know how to exactly that's what i was
most pleasantly surprised about because
nas at this point in his career he's
certified you know he's a legend nothing
to prove yeah he doesn't have to change
anything but he did
and i was and it wasn't like he's doing
something that's like completely
uncharacteristic yeah it's just like an
evolution of him and it was really
refreshing to hear and there were like
legitimate head knockers in there you
know
now
what i realized though is because this
is king's disease too and then there was
kings disease one i hadn't even heard
kings disease one but i started looking
at the song credits and i realized what
had happened na is linked up with hit
boy hit boy was the executive producer
on both albums and i was telling you not
one of nas is like biggest weakness and
crutch before was he just did not
have good taste in picking beats you
know i don't think he ever i mean listen
i don't know naz personally yeah but it
seemed like that wasn't something he
cared about because he relied on his
lyricism right right right and and he
had that in spades but it's like come on
man like if you want to have it be
entertaining not just like this deep
prolific lyricism
then you got to have dope beats with it
you know especially if you're trying to
sell records but like like you said
maybe that wasn't a priority for him i
don't know i don't know what the deal is
or maybe he just sucked at picking beats
you know yeah maybe he's just like his
ear for beats is just not that good but
when you got one guy who's also a proven
hitmaker in hitboy who's doing the album
chances are he's gonna produce
firefighters some bangers yeah and then
on here like yeah rare was my favorite
track obviously but
i i talked to you about this through
text the other day yes death row east
yeah
that was an incredible song to have in
2021 because it's like almost 25 years
later after the fact the whole history
behind it and like for people you don't
know explain it to me yeah so
death row was a huge west coast that's
why i wore this shirt today you know
like this is basically death row this
was snoop shug dre and pock so death row
at the time was not only the number one
hip-hop uh record uh record label it was
a number one music label they were just
like killing it bangers after yeah
like snoop they were just killing it and
then it got to the point where
there was a beef
forming between pock and biggie and then
it became
death row versus
east coast and then it evolved into west
coast vs east coast you know
and at the peak of kind of that drama
death row had the audacity to form death
row east and basically their whole thing
was
we're gonna take over we're gonna come
over here we're gonna show your people
how to get paid they're gonna love it
we're gonna put all the hottest east
coast records on our label and we're
gonna take over your territory this is
our territory now right you guys can
find a video about it look up death row
east on youtube and you'll see poc with
suge and he's basically going off on it
basically what had happened at that time
though was because this is right around
park's death i think
um
there was beef pocket beef now with with
uh with jay with biggie with mob deep
with nas like pretty much all the big
east coast heads right
and
nas
when at the vma uh music awards the mtv
music awards
uh poc was there and the whole
death row camp was there and nasa's
younger brother jungle who's a part of
bravehearts
he
saw pak and i think he kind of like said
some words and they kind of got into it
a little bit nothing like a scuffle but
there was kind of like b form in there
did you did you hear did you hear the uh
the snoop interview about what happened
so that's the thing nas corrected snoop
oh did he he did cause snoops snoop's
whole take on it was they ran into each
other at central park nas was with his
goons like hundred of them pock was with
like his crew hundred and [ __ ] was about
to go down but then pock was like nah
man
like
if you got [ __ ]
you know let me know right now right but
nas was saying nah it's all good like
it's cool pog we good and and
snoop's story was pac saying well i'm
gonna dish like i got these dis records
coming out and then and i'm gonna put
him out and you ain't gonna say [ __ ]
about it then yeah right that's kind of
what snoop was painting but history
refutes that even park zone camp
napoleon from outlaws had told this
story nas
gave his rendition of the story so
basically what actually happened was
there was an after party where they did
collide and they did have all of those
goons with them pot scoops and nazis
goons all of them were strapped up right
so they're waiting for [ __ ] to pop off
like oh [ __ ] this this might get really
ugly really fast with this amount of
people and this many straps but
how napoleon told it and how nas told it
was basically like
parking nods got together they talked
recognized that there was some
misunderstandings they defused the
situation and basically said it was all
good and pock even was gonna take nas
out of his dis records that he had
nasa's name in when he got back oh [ __ ]
when he got back to the west coast yeah
but what had happened was he went to
vegas after that nas even went out to
vegas to do a truce like an official
visible truce of like so that east coast
west coast beef is dead we're deading it
in public like so you guys see this
that's what was supposed to happen and
that's what they agreed on but then pock
died a couple of days after that's crazy
he got shot in vegas while naz was
having a concert in vegas and nas found
out during his concert that park died
and and you could see it there's footage
of it they announced pock's death at at
the concert that's crazy yeah you think
if there was that kind of animosity
between them naz would have given him
that respect in that moment you know
what i mean so that was kind of the
whole story of what went down was like
nah snoop's version i don't know where
snoop's version uh
like came from why he's getting it like
that but from what napoleon was saying
like part of the outlaws it was that
nobody could hear what nas and poc were
talking about it only them two knew yeah
what was said and so that's what was
said they were getting ready to dead the
beef because it's like all right it's
gone far enough you know enough is
enough like let's squash it two generals
you know east coast west coast generals
diffusing the beef right there so nobody
else gets hurt no this [ __ ] don't turn
into something that doesn't have to
and then nas talking about it on the
death row east track when i saw the
title death row east i was like oh [ __ ]
this is gonna be classic nas the
historian the storyteller like
and it was i was not disappointed and it
was so dope for him to kind of like
retell because i've seen interviews with
nazim to pass him talking about it but
then him putting it into a song form
because i feel like that's a point in
hip-hop's history that's not really
talked about a lot but was
really really important and monumental
well because the story that everybody
remembers is is biggie versus pop right
right piggy versus pog biggie versus
pock and there's this whole this is so
much that we don't know about that like
who really killed pock
everything is all speculation yeah right
suge knight
into that conversation yeah [ __ ]
is a thug yeah but suge knight is he's a
disgusting human being i mean time and
time again he's probably if you're
watching this i do not
i do not i do not agree with this man i
don't even know him
i got you on my shirt but not because i
like you bro cuz this is just you were
on the the you know iconic uh death row
cover but yeah yeah it's crazy because
like snoop's rendition of that story
when he was telling and he was talking
about you know when they came together
and talked that's what park said poc was
like listen like i'm gonna put out this
diss track and you're not gonna say sh
if you respect me so much he goes yo
park i respect you yeah yeah you know if
you respect me so much when i put this
out you're not gonna say [ __ ] yeah and
you know now it's like oh cool yeah he's
like of course now i love you i respect
you and then snoop was kind of relaying
it as like pock believed that he just
son nas right but in snoop's eyes he
said that he didn't stun anybody naz let
him live that day and so that's how he
kind of viewed it but it's interesting
how it was refuted yeah yeah no so
basically it was like kind of agreeing
to peace terms like just recognizing
look maybe there was some
misunderstanding because i think park
thought nas was taking some shots at him
in some records that nas had but nas
apparently said that he cleared that up
to pogba like nah
i wasn't taking shots he's a very
polarizing human being
oh he's so polarizing
like we forget dude like when we see
this guy of like how prolific he was and
like how his just charisma and energy
and his voice commanded your attention
and like he made you believe what he was
talking about made you want to follow
him made you want to like you know
really ride for the dude he was only 25
when he died man he was still a kid
that's crazy yeah but like when we see
him we think he's like 30 something
right like he seems like this full-grown
adult with this like really um diverse
life experience and like and he did
though he did have a crazy life in a
short span of time
his mom was like highly educated too
right she was part of the black panther
movement yeah you know um
so pock was also went to an art school
growing up yeah so poetry was his thing
and so like he had the gift of gab he
had the writing skills and poetry skills
he just put it into rap form you know
and through that obviously he did kind
of go down a path of like
a little bit of destruction and like
legal troubles and all of that but at
the end of the day shot a cop
i don't did he shoot a cop yeah i think
that's why he went to jail because he
shot a cop well there was a few reasons
i mean there was the rape allegations
you know i mean pock got shot he got
shot five times in new york in the
studio when he's recording over there
and he thought he got set up by one of
the east coast heads you know that maybe
diddy and biggie knew knew about it and
never like told him about and that's why
he got super paranoid and started really
beefing with the east it was like they
moved to the west side yeah it's like
y'all [ __ ] set me up you know
and i thought like we were brothers um
and so like yeah it that was
that was a really crazy time because you
gotta understand when we talk about east
coast west coast beef if you were in
each other's territory and they knew you
were from another side like that could
get you killed that could get you killed
yeah that's how crazy it got um and you
know we talk about this and so i mean
that's even just to wrap back why you
know i made that statement um the pop
column rapper versus the the rapper that
makes me want to piss while i sit down
like this is what i'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah i'm not saying that i'm
glorifying this no no i'm just talking
about the beef that we grew up with
right to the point where a bunch of
asian kids in my neighborhood right
or just everybody in the neighborhood in
general we were claiming west sides
super art right like it's like yo west
coast till i [ __ ] die yeah it's all
about west coast
it started bleeding into pop culture
like these kids who clearly aren't gang
members or whatever we're just all like
west side i remember as a kid i couldn't
do this and this [ __ ] used to piss me
off if you guys are watching
when you cross that [ __ ] finger you
do it extra hard son and as a kid i
couldn't do this so i started forcing it
and practicing it all the time and then
now you can
not so much this one though bro is a w
to the max west coast baby yeah no but
yeah man like so that's why listening to
nas and like him being from that era the
golden era of hip-hop him being an
intricate part of all of that stuff
happening it was just so cool and
refreshing and i was pleasantly
surprised like i said listening to his
album so there might be a bit of a bias
there but for me i definitely enjoyed
his album way more than i did donda or
certified loverboy just because it's
just felt more authentic and raw you
know yeah it felt felt real there was
evolution it was different from the
stuff that he was doing before the
production was [ __ ] right yeah
drake's felt like every his last two
albums and then kanye's was kanye's [ __ ]
was just [ __ ] scattered
and i didn't enjoy it yeah surprised you
didn't listen to it man i was spending
that [ __ ] consistently yeah rare is
probably to me the hottest track that i
heard this year for sure i would say
hands down for me too no question no
question because listen i'm a i'm a huge
j cole fan
right his last album was decent yeah it
was it didn't hit as hard for me yeah i
was i told you about this i there was a
sense of slight disappointment based on
the la leakers freestyle because i
thought he was gonna be like now granted
of course he had bars in the album but i
was i don't know that gave me a certain
feeling of like oh [ __ ] this is going to
be like another level you know but it
didn't quite get there it didn't really
yeah and production too was a little bit
very hit or miss for me so
i enjoyed it but not as much as i was
hoping i would enjoy it yeah and so so
you hate j cole i get it nah j cole is
still you know him and kendrick are like
leaders of this generation for sure but
nasa's album from a hip-hop standpoint
for sure was the best hip-hop album so
far for me this year um and it's which
is funny talking about even the east
coast west coast [ __ ] people don't
understand cause you had mentioned kanye
having ghost riders and then the whole
meek bill and meek mill and drake beef
stem from meek mill saying drake had
ghost riders right
ghost riders is such a big part of the
game like you look at some of the most
iconic west coast tracks still dre that
is snoop dogg and dr dre who wrote that
track jay-z yeah jay wrote the whole
track he even did the uh reference
vocals in dre's voice and snoop's voice
to reference them that's crazy yeah the
whole entire track was written by by
jay-z the most one of the most iconic
west coast songs that's correct i didn't
know that yeah so that's the thing is
like people don't don't know these
things right they just think like oh
these guys are you know trey's like the
quintessential west coast guy no but
he's not really a writer all his [ __ ] is
written by ghost right hitman is a big
ghost writer for him you know kendrick
ghost wrote his [ __ ] eminem ghost wrote
as [ __ ] jay ghost wrote his [ __ ] you
know
so you guys got to realize that too
within like when we talk about like
authenticity or whatever
music business is just that it's a
business it's about like whatever is
going to be the best product possible
yes it's and i think for that's very
that reigns true for a lot of people who
are looking for radio hits you know
obviously you're not going to find
somebody who's going to write something
for jay because he has a very very
specific flow right and his writing
process is very very specific and he's a
prolific writer he doesn't need a
ghostwriter exactly he's pretty much
good to go if there are other people on
his song credits it's most likely
because there's like on the hook or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense yeah like even if he might be um
saying like wrapping the hook or singing
the hook there might have been writers
that helped write the chorus but the
verses that's 100 him you know
if you guys even watch this just go on
youtube and just uh watch
i think it was blueprint but i forgot
which song he was writing but it's just
him freestyling and writing his
freestyle though
exactly then it was a song well the dude
doesn't write yeah you know he he writes
everything in his head that's [ __ ]
crazy man that's crazy every single song
that he's ever recorded is all up here
nothing is written down you know it was
the uh the
the yay and the the jay-z album watch
the throne dog i i actually just uh
re-listened to it yeah that album is so
[ __ ] good dude well speaking of that
the n in paris was produced by hit boy
and he's the one who who produced that
sounds so good yeah produced when that
was the single i believe the lead single
off the album so
for you guys that don't know again hit
boy this is the guy who produced kings
disease one and two and which is why you
got these fire bangers in there you know
yeah but yeah man i i
i'm
really glad that uh
i heard that song in your car that night
because i i dude it just went completely
under the radar maybe i just been so
caught up in my own [ __ ] you haven't
been paying attention to these releases
but
man it was really nice and refreshing to
hear somebody because naz is one of like
my all-time artists too you know even
though prior to that i would say like
godson was my last favorite nas album
which is like 20 long like 2006
you know 2005 or something
but yeah this king's disease ii um
it was a fire out she was so good if you
guys haven't listened to it take it you
know
give it a listen man i think it has a
little bit of everything for old heads
and young heads yeah and let's look all
of this let's wrap it up by saying i got
no hate for drake or kanye like dave
look there's no argument to what they've
done and the type of [ __ ] that they put
out all i'm saying is personally with
these two projects it wasn't necessarily
my cup of tea and i didn't enjoy that
much um y'all can hate me for it for
whatever but i got drake i got yay on my
playlist i got their songs yeah it's
just this was not
what i was hoping
it
could have been i feel like yeah let the
hate comments roll in
whatever man it's all good well guys you
could catch every genius brain episode
every thursdays and sundays you can see
ed at ed2 on instagram and make sure
that you guys cop your secret society we
got some new [ __ ] droppings
fire dropping man there's something off
camera that we can't show you right now
i i really want to show you because it's
just [ __ ] dope just just wait for it
though just wait for it yeah but we'll
see you all next time every thursday
sundays and we will catch you guys on
another [ __ ] episode peace